hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly chacho every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com I'm
your host Daniel während by Justin hey
walls and Peter Brown who was thankfully
worn his glasses so that we can tell you
two apart thank you very much gentlemen
I event people come up to me at Comic
Con last year I had someone come up to
me god I love your work at gamespot
you're one of my favorite editors and
then he mentioned he was like that video
that you did with with this thing about
a computer I was like what do you think
my name is your Peter Brown like yes I
internet speed a breath that would have
been harsh to correct him and peter
brian though we're so happy to have you
on so you can tell us all about you tues
favorite Resident Evil game revelations
to steady you to joke yeah you remember
that [ __ ] tomb raider song no yeah
was nothing I'll just say you all right
i have no idea i got my one you to
reference in for this week at resident
evil revelations 2 part 1 episode 1
episode while i guess this is the first
of a four-part resident evil sequel
revelation of the 10th game i think in
the residue of franchise yeah well i
don't know Wow core franchise we just
get rid of those light gun games just
put no over there and maybe so not quite
tense if you're going by the core games
is no Veronica yeah not one no yeah we
count that tell me about chapter one
because I know you've played some more
but you can only talk about that one
said where you went up on gamespot today
yeah and what do you think of it so far
I'll give you seven so it's technically
a good great all right I'm selection
it's very fitting as an episode because
Capcom is treating this like a TV show
you know like it it ends next week on
Resident Evil Revelations in this net
but um but is next week right yeah
they're doing in weekly episodes at when
the last one comes out you can actually
buy the game you'll get two extra
episodes 0 which is a bit interesting
but anyway you know it's uh it's good so
far as Resident Evil games go it's
certainly not the scariest it's not the
worst either but it seems to play more
into the more
modern resident evils as far as like
camera angles in the way do you go
around blow and should i will share
everything yeah I mean it's you know
obviously there are no fixed camera
angles and it kind of feels a little bit
like resident evil 4 and 5 when it comes
to the action sequences it's not as
over-the-top as six oh god it's a set
between five and six right I'm likewise
possibly you're playing with Moira
Burton Moira Burton and yeah but Claire
Redfield but then also Barry Burton and
a mysterious girl named natalia hmm but
you basically the gist is is like
there's this company called Terra save
they have this ridiculous corporate
video at the beginning and it's sort of
preface apart II and Claire and Moira
are kidnaps and they wake up in this
horrible cell and somebody is sort of
orchestrating this big event for them
and they have to try to escape from here
and they just run into like you know
these horrible abominations that are
just trying to murder them and how old
is Moira when you're playing her it's a
good question they don't I don't
actually they don't say hrishi tween
string between but she actually works
for this company so she's at least 16
okay but I think you must be more nerd
20s do you think that the the dark
companies in Resident Evil abide by
normal us working laws good question
this one is actually like an inner like
a there like a front facing company
that's there to like clean up
bioterrorism grot got it yeah that's
some bedtime something's gonna do it and
I hear there's some tween ish cursing in
this game yeah something about a bucket
of Fox at some stage don't care yeah
they actually cleaned it up since the
preview events that we used to go to I
did you ever go to use any of those so
it was saltier before you have a soldier
before there was this line the Maire had
where she was trying to say like what
the hell is this and when she really
said was what the [ __ ] is that me and
they capitalized every letter in the
word [ __ ] thanks we they got rid of that
but did they rerecord it so like this
it's like you she said before like what
the [ __ ] is that mitten like someone
went back 90 that doesn't make sense yes
arriba cord and i believe they replaced
it with one of the things on my list i
have every line that Moira says where
she swears on a piece of paper in
chapter one in chapter one so presumably
this
mortality of this cursing too well I'm
too or two more at least three more oh
no spoilers fair enough oh so he does it
get better than that does it get better
than what the [ __ ] I pray oh yeah I mean
she says typical things like what the
hell are you doing stuff like that
that's kind of boring but she has ones
where she says I mean what in the moist
barrel of Fox okay more lies a grocer I
know Melissa but but who says something
like a moist barrel of [ __ ] that's not
it doesn't even make sense she also
several who the [ __ ] is quoting poetry
[ __ ] you Hollywood that was aiming close
too easy also Barry can kiss my ass that
God is it that guy [ __ ] and granny
swears about everything whitey refers to
her father Barry yeah she doesn't like
her dad apparently but what is granny
swearing you know science or any ball
like thingy you know you go bowling and
you do an underhand so a great yeah
alright so it's like I yes I got soft
like soft lob she's not a granny square
she says things like you moist bucket of
[ __ ] the last line that she has part it
would be for a moist bucket of hearts
because it's granny square the last line
you hear from her and she's calling me
there I think it might be whether
Moonves is going to put this over there
she's in a very different situation in
his last thing here Jesus is anyone even
out there [ __ ] [ __ ] on a stick ok
that's how her character closes out
episode 1 great is this swearing up a
storm and like I don't know she plays an
important role in the plot but otherwise
she just seems like she's there to sort
of be this angsty like young brash
person but I don't think anyone who
wrote this game has ever talked to
anyone or does it sound like that it's
like old people writing dialogue totally
a different generation yeah like there
are some that there's sometimes where
she swears that are fine but for a lot
of times it's such a trihard great
publisher then following in the long
tradition of resident evil dog being
completely ridiculous and funny for the
wrong reasons I'd like to talk about how
the game is good though ok I'll get all
poor swearing and I want to represent
the good stuff once you get to play as
Barry Burton and this girl italia the
buddy system gets a lot better like you
have to play with Moira when you're
playing with Claire she's kind of
useless Natalya this young girl who can
kind of sneak by enemies and they won't
notice her there are some scenes where
it's it's actually like a really scary
moment but Barry isn't the right fit
even though he's got like an assault
rifle a minigun yeah in a pistol this
young girl this little tiny girl is like
the the right man for the job and you
really do get that sense of being scared
because it's just sort of like crap I
have to use her but she's so vulnerable
and you can't see what's out there and
so this game does have a few moments of
tension that are really good that do
deliver what I think people who like
Resident Evil games are looking for it's
just kind of stuck in the middle of a
bunch of stuff that's not so great right
yeah so is the game split into two
sections then almost we're like you're
two different sets of buddies is that
how this plays out yeah so you finish
the section with Claire and Moira and
then it switches to bury and that's
great crawl yeah it she's good at the
Crouch cross it feels very the last of
us in some ways we like when I keep
looking right and you see that the young
girls sneaking past yep well zombies
needs a big guy with huge guns did
letting your daughter do all the work
and also Barry Burton sounds exactly
like Liam Neeson and hey why not he's
going to rescue his kidnapped daughter
that's fair enough there you go
excellent so the review for episode 1 is
live on the site will you be doing
reviews every week then for next couple
weeks every week and then I'm going to
do a review of the entire game right
which will also be there's a boxed
version as well like its legit review i
think that's the only way you get the
extra two episodes i could be wrong you
might be able to buy a season pass that
would make sense but cool all right we
look forward to talking to you next week
of a lot of that episode 2 and we'll let
us know what you think about resident
evil revelations 2 in the comments below
let us know what you think of moist
buckets of [ __ ] yeah we'll be back next
week with an update on all the curses in
the second episode of that game all
right alexa ray corriea is here to talk
about Mordor no better lady for the job
poorly back at the second first of all
going to check out the latest trailer
for the Lords of fallen DLC
shadow of Mordor was a fantastic game
that came in last year in fact it's
picked up gamespot's Game of the Year
award and they believes in a bunch of
DLC over Christmas and beyond and the
latest one I think it's the last one
just came in today alexa ray corriea
expert on all things talking in the
office you've been playing it since
yesterday what do you think about this
expansion that is basically sort of
fixing the ending of the game so so the
problem with the problem with the ending
of shadow of mordor is the final boss is
essentially a quick time event center
for tournaments and you don't actually
get to fight Sauron you know the whole
game is sort of like go against Sauron
so the what this does is it gives you an
entire new campaigns about 10 missions
long and you're fighting as Kelly rim
bore who is who is the ghost that's
attached Italian to fuel the Wraith
powers but he's still alive in this
version before all that stuff happens
spoilers if you haven't played before
and he is the bright Lord yes it was
Frank Lord and Smeagol was referring to
him as right he um it's the name I think
bright bright Lord is and an epithet
that monolith has described to him but
Calvin border in the lord rings in lord
the rings floor is the forger of the
rings of power ye SAR on pretends to be
a good guy basically and shows up at his
home and it's like hey let's make some
jewelry yeah he's a master craftsman so
he's like sure but yeah i'll make some
jewelry yeah let's do it so there are
six tiny we make sense of rings that are
super powerful I don't know of course
Alexa for anyone who doesn't know is a
scholar of cold I am a scholar jokin I
went to college for this stuff and i
rememba da games but the whole premise
is that monoliths took that relationship
with Sauron and Kellerman war and sauron
does in the books trick Kellerman bore
into making the one ring like by
accident but what monolith has done is
they sort of made it so that Keller and
bore is sort of forced into it and at
the last minute pulls back and as you
can see he has the ring like he steals
the ring from Sauron literal
if you want to watch the cutscene he
literally like sauron's holding any
pokes his finger in the ice and runs
away with it I'll do it so Kellerman war
is using the ring to do the same thing
talion was doing in shadow of mordor
which is subjugate these orcs and it's
interesting because the bright Lord
focuses on domination rather than
killing so you have a whole new set of
Nemesis does the Nemesis system you have
52 warchiefs thank you playing in the
first section or the second section of
mortals there in the first map ok it's
pre-fall Mordor which you can see by all
of this new gritty grit yes and darkness
and sometimes Sauron will talk to you
and the edges of the screen will go red
cuz neurons talking you know piece of
[ __ ] ok basically so new war Chiefs you
have to dominate all of them there's
five um the interesting thing is in the
original in the mini game you could go
in and essentially take out a were
Chiefs bodyguards one by one and make
him a week or so he has no protection
you can't do that in a bright Lord
because you're only dominating them
because you can only dominate them and
will can't take out the bodyguards like
like you can't you can't take them out
you can't take them out first you have
to go after them like immediately so
it's you against these were Chiefs who
start at level 20 so they're already
very very difficult you can't done so
what I did you know and I think the last
portion of shadow wood or was you had to
you dominated the war chiefs and then
you essentially just use them to replace
the existing works yes which was super
easy well this one is a little different
if you do that no like the whole board
like they're all level 20 they're all
very difficult what you can do which is
something that I actually really
appreciate it is you can dominate the
lower the lower or it's like you can run
through an area and they'll be like
having dinner and you'll be like mine
mine mine and 94 guys oh cool and that
adds to your existing retinue of guys so
if you're completing a mission and you
have 21 really hard mission was you have
to either the big group of Orcs and you
have to keep 15 branded orcs in your
retinue for tour for two minutes okay
and the works that are not serving you
will kill the orcs that are serving you
so that number is constantly going down
so you have to quickly brand more to
keep them up and if you get under I
think 10 the count resets
minutes resets so that sounds like a
whole new like intention of focus
because one of the other things you told
me yesterday when you were playing was
that one of the like Maine I guess
attacks in the game that was so handy
and I kept upgrading was being able to
just fire arrows one by one by one yes
slow the game down yeah but the slow mo
is gone they're almost gone I talked to
the design director Michael de platter
last week and he told me that they
removed that slow down because in Lord
of the Rings lure the elves are all very
skilled with bows and very quick with
them so it seemed pretty you know seemed
like a good idea to just take out that
slow down because l's just know how to
do it it's not idea but you know how to
do it on controlling and Alvin and I
know and the perspective goes into over
it goes like into almost first person so
it's really so it's not like a shooter
element to it now and you have to work
very quickly however your arrows are
more powerful you can one hitch 11 hit
shoot an orc and then he's done I think
you can you know shoot from far away and
he's I think this guy need yeah and you
can dominate now with arrows as well
excellent can swoop in and grab them so
how are you actually enjoying it then is
it is it worthwhile is it an essential
thing to play if you were finally get
like I loved Mordor I kind of would like
any excuse to go back and play it again
like is it sort of an essential addition
to the game um I would say I think it's
very very different it's a similar but
different experience to shadow of Mordor
and it's very it's very very difficult
if you did fine in Mordor and you loved
it you want more I think it'd be worth
going back and trying this out sort of
offers things from a different
perspective and you get to sites are on
and you get everything from tell
reporters point of view and whereas tell
ian was sort of like you sort of felt
for him killed members actually kind of
he's almost a little nasty looks very
very like like crude in a little crazy
um but i like it i really like it i'm
not quite done with it but I like that
it's offering that sort of a challenge I
mean yeah feel like more Dory go back to
it fantastic well in one thing for did
you start with all of your powers
because I felt like when I was flanked
cheto mortar was a lot of fun it was
like it was a good challenge and they
got to the end works like oh my god this
is like I'm just oh yeah i'm basically
jumping over people bringing them and
then I just have an army of Orcs who are
doing all the killing for me yeah so
does it be physical harder after that
that it was a little too ya know
you felt very icy door shutter motor I
think we all felt pretty powerful you
start bright Lord telegram boards all
his skills are unlocked you have all of
them available to you however when I was
talking earlier about how you have to
sort of focus on dominating the works in
the Nemesis system instead of killing
them if you kill them you get runes for
your weapons which are the only things
you can upgrade if you're focusing on
dominating you can't kill them so you
have to sort of make decisions like
depending on who you're killing like do
I kill this measly little guy for like a
for like eighteen percent health upgrade
or do i dominate them will that help me
in the long run and I kind of I liked
about the first game and I sort of like
that here but ya know you have
everything you are ready to go out
together our Freight Lord you are the
bright Lord X I'm ready to go Alexa
thank you so much for coming on yeah I
thought about that I gotta pick that up
later on that's the available two day
for the general public and please let us
know what you think about that of course
gamespot's game of the year for 2014
shadow of Mordor in the comments below
alright it's been a little bit of a snow
slow news week for the past couple weeks
I feel like part of those to do with
what's going on next week he said we yet
is benefit of us you a week oh boy what
it's also been a bit of us in a week for
everywhere else it's not San Francisco
here [ __ ] snow joke you said it's no
joke no Mary's not like you shouldn't be
laughing you're going to pax east yeah
we are no are you right my aunt my old
stomping grounds yeah no do much some
samba smoke and our readers I'm sure no
Eddie makuu out in Boston yeah one of
our regular news writers we're bringing
him to GDC to sunny California kidding
me for three days and then he's going by
then we're gonna send it back into the
snow haha poor Eddie well speaking of
these Islamic Carlos a fan GDC is in the
back easy but to come on until it's all
about the game developers conference
we're just starting in San Francisco
next week but until then we have the
latest Raider for super or fir street
fighter 5 it looks like Charlie Nash is
making his way to the series and he's
looking pretty good so let's check out
the reveal which came at just earlier
today
personal demo tomorrow
you
Oh
a game developers conference GDC is on
right here in San Francisco next week
and we were very happy to be joined mr.
strong and Carlos let's sir how are you
you must be super not busy at the moment
right yes a few things going on but I
thought I'd special i have to come out
with you guys just for a few minutes or
considering your offices but like a
block and a half down the street yeah i
got here like an hour and a half early
because i got excited and then I was
like I just walked to the hook ourselves
is like a new blocks all right so it
really good one of the things about GDC
that I find funny after sort of joining
the games prices up for years and years
I used to watch the awards and the IGF
forwards and GDC Awards on gamespot and
see all the news that came out of it but
it's like it's one of the most
interesting awards that's on but I know
for people who are sort of outside of
the industry of our don't actually
attend it's kind of an unknown so like
what is the GDC awards for folks who
maybe aren't familiar with sure yeah I
mean in that case sir in this case GD c
stands for the games or the first choice
awards and you know and we're obviously
one of the one of the few Awards out
there that was really voted entirely by
the community so so and that's to say
our community of game developers know so
so we spend a lot of time picking about
a thousand people from the industry and
they end up voting every year on the
best titles and the best thing about it
is it's actually in the same evening as
independent games first of all so you
get two awards for the price of one and
we get through them both in under two
hours most of the time yeah which is
reasonably hip resistance and inhale of
the Oscars nowadays like yeah three and
a half absolutely miss mr. Schaeffer is
reprising his his role as the emcee of
the Disney Awards yeah that's why I'm
Tim Schafer was back he does he does
every other year yeah seems like it
because it turns out he's running a game
company or so the family has to work on
that and needless to say he's not
written one word of his script so far oh
really yeah yeah he's probably not
watching but he's renowned actually and
notorious for that right
knowing us a procrastinator yes and as
you one you he managed to make a flash
game about not writing the script oh
really if you go look online you'll find
someone don't find our cover this is
flash game which he did with with a
bunch of people and it's all about how
he hasn't written the script yet any
genuinely sent us that with a week to go
and I said he was like guys to Robert
over I haven't written a word but I've
done this flash it's a game about not
writing a word has that nathan fellow
copy made any flash game this year is
hosting the IGF Awards I'm not Nathan
actually has got those draft of the
script nice so so yeah so Nathan Vella
hosting the independent games festival
from from cafe of super time force fame
and yeah yeah and we're really excited
he yes he hosted last year and he's a
really good host and again we try as
much as possible to get people from the
game developer gassy hosting because
like you know we don't have hit the
against other awards but have you know
shall we say more polished host
someone's but we really like the genuine
hosts who are kind of kind of goofing
off and I guess that's the thing with
GDC is that it's a it's a conference for
game developers so of course you should
have a it's it's very much a sort of a I
guess it must be really interesting for
people who work tirelessly in various
parts of the world so finally have a
week to come together and share ideas
and share experiences what's the sort of
main focus for people who attends the
conference itself well it's interesting
because you're right and one of the good
things about Judy see is there's so many
people know those who are like Indies
and working solo or working in small
groups and it's so great for them all
all come Sam Cisco and get a chance to
hang out because they you know they
often don't get to see the people that
they talked to on social media all year
but you know I think yeah I mean you
know there's always a bunch of focuses
around the show and what we've done is
we've gradually built up like a whole
bunch of kind of summit within the main
show snow for example we have a summit
just about India member summit about
free to play we have something about
getting narrative only but actually
about you this year we have some new
summits and and we have for the first
time in eSports summit oh I just kind of
you know if thoughts it's not
necessarily a novel idea but we've kind
of made it a rule we don't necessarily
produce a summit like the very first
opportunity jerk reaction yeah otherwise
we would have had
you know like a 3d TV summer right yeah
perhaps not the best idea yeah so so so
we try and climb it so we're somewhere
you know i mean the hype curve kicks in
there but at some point you realize
actually there's something on going here
that will benefit everyone and i think
actually we actually just servo amongst
our developers and we found that
although only about fifteen percent of
our audience our are currently working
on in the eSport again they consider any
sport I think about eighty-five percent
of them think it's going to be a big
thing in the future and also it's a lot
of lessons that regular developers can
learn from what's going on these bots
which is you know there's just there's
just so many good learnings for house
stuff displays on on streaming you know
streaming is really important how
multiplayer competition works so you
know we have a bunch of interesting
talks that's on Tuesday we have we have
a whole day whole day program related to
that and we have for example the lead
lead design of League of Legends is
going to be interviewed by Frank Lance
we have a talk on on counter-strike go
modding we have a talk on starcraft 2
interface modding we have a talk on on
the role of develop women in eSports and
yeah as a whole bunch of interesting
stuff there so I think it's going to be
good there's so much going on at GDC I
know here on gamespot we're going to be
streaming the the awards the IGF awards
and a few select panels a few select
panels as well I'll here actually there
they are on screen right now and include
we also will have a recording of John
Carmack ski know which might run on just
a little bit longer than they know he's
already gone yeah so so yes so John cork
no so John Carmack is speaking on
Wednesday and it's kind of a featured
talk after the after all flash forward
which which kicks off the day and we
left him a little time in to lunch
because he's already said in this talk
description the intends to go until
someone pulls my stories with a light
like a hook yeah that's pretty much what
we're expecting but yeah yeah it's it's
difficult in GDC is just such a great
time for developers to learn a lot about
the industry and I think for us and for
our readers and it's really interesting
to get that inside look to learn about a
lot of things that usually are kind of
hidden from us but there's also a lot of
news especially recently like you know
people are doing some reveals
hardware reveals software reveals you
guys try to push back on that at all to
make sure that it stays focused on the
developers you ask the interesting
question because we have had in the past
we have had keynotes to the show and
although you know i would say john
carmack is like a big talk we officially
kind of have stayed away from from
keynotes recently because there's been
the thing in the past where people have
been tempted to announce things to the
world virtually there's a bunch of
developers in front of them you know you
know certain it's difficult because you
know whilst you might want to talk about
you know particular things such as XNA
that's very relevant to developers
there's a bunch of other stuff you also
want to get out about about your fat
form so you can I start sighs I think
what we decided this like we're really
happy with for people to make
announcements like around the show and
obviously we're super excited that you
know Val seems to be announcing things
and we do have we'd have talks on this
type of thing but I think you know we
definitely think the e3 is the place for
platform holders and large publishers to
be making kind of the here's our lineup
kind of thing and I think what we're
seeing with Judy see if people are
announcing new hardware at the show and
they are showing a bunch of games about
the show often kind of you know in the
peripheral area we do have also a quite
a lot of table games around our show
floor but they're much more kind of
games that are trying to get some you
know some interest with public's
publishers are under shopping in there
yeah I mean yeah there's no shortage of
game conferences now for people to
announce though if they if they still
want to but like you said perhaps one of
the most interesting things about the
announcements were hopefully going to be
seeing between as valve yesterday
showing off their their steam universe
thing or like talking about it being at
GDC if V or is actually going to be
something that tangibly works then
surely the company's several of which
seem to be at GDC shopping around need
to sell it to developers before
consumers will get the hook on it what
do you think about all the different
viewer stuff that seems to be that's
going to be available at GDC you next
week yeah I think it's fascinating
because it really has been you know the
VR Tech has now been available to
developers for full little while so
we're starting to see games they're
starting to look pretty good you know we
have games like a
a drift which is yeah which is the guy
made of North working on we have a game
called classroom aquatic that I'm kind
of a fan of where you're the title yeah
you know you're like a dolphin and you
have to cheat on a multiple choice test
okay and you're in like an old school
classroom and the teacher is like a
diver and you have to avoid the teacher
noticing and so I still have a
movement-based ah it's pretty bizarre
only available arc yeah but it actually
speaks to the factually speaks to the
fact that you know some of the use of
interface issues of the are just
completely different ya like like like
like the fact is if you're moving your
head and your hammock to encroach is
moving that's such a different feel such
different gameplay feel to most other
you know games yeah they're going to
alien isolation was a completely
different experience when you had the
rift on and then also like games like
what is it be work together or everyone
explodes or shut up right oh yeah yeah
keep talking keep talking I took away
the opposite of what i was thinking
where you're literally got your hands in
here you're just interacting with like
with visuals yeah and it seems like this
is we've been talking about you are like
it's a it's a massive news attraction on
the side like people are really
interested in it what do you hope comes
out of via or GDC this year do you think
is there a worried that if there's like
three or four different platform holders
who were like making their own little
individual thing that it'll just
fragment that space up too much and
consumers won't get the best uh yeah I
mean I think the biggest issue with
peripherals is always fragmentation and
getting to a big install base so I
definitely think the lid is a concern
that if you have too many systems and
not one unified standard then maybe
there may be there will be an issue but
I think that's a little bit being
alleviated nowadays by game engines like
unity and unreal because basically if
you are a developer then then you've got
to know that unity is going to help help
you make sure you're going to be on
these platforms very easily or unreal or
any other game engine so if you're
building in one of those engines it
should be much easier to port to all the
systems and they didn't used to be the
case and that's why you would feel a
little you know a bunch of conversions
coming up very late after yeah but I
mean that's not the only thing but yeah
I mean I think it really I think one
thing that did people didn't appreciate
about VR is I do think that you know in
many cases conventional console games
don't work well in VR
you needed just a whole different kind
of game play experience and I do wonder
sometimes whether that game play
experience is going to be completely
accessible to the mainstream who are
used to like ultra fast ultra kind of
action based games because you can only
whip your head around so quickly well
you know when you're when you're going
to be up I think there's going to be a
bunch of really interesting experiences
and I think the fact that valve is
supporting it you know so strongly or we
haven't quite worked out how yet but you
know the fact that valve will have
something and certainly sony has
something an oculus has something and
the certainly nvidia seems to be making
announcement the show has been some
rumors that that that's we are related
as well although that hasn't been
confirmed yeah there's starting to be a
few practical to tell there yeah a lot
of people are interested in it for sure
Dustin I was going to say you know there
are so just so many panels in so much
going on and I know that you're gonna be
ridiculously busy during the week but is
there anything that you're already like
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna not be able
to do any other work I'm gonna go to
this panel i really want to check this
out guys I'm gonna I'm not gonna be able
to work during that time I really want
to see you know that's a really good
question i think i think what i really
enjoy the classic game post-mortems we
have you know every year we've started
that for our 25th anniversary which was
I think three or four years ago so now
we've had maybe 16 to 20 of these
classic post-mortems and all available
for free streaming on our G on our GDC
vault website by the way and I think
number the more archived on them as well
so yeah and then an actually this year
we have we start control is one of the
ones we have which is which obviously a
real classic strategy title we have yars
revenge as well which is very early
Atari 2600 game but I'm particularly
excited about that because Howard Scott
Warshaw is the guy who made that and he
also famously made et exercises which he
made in six weeks okay and I was talking
about that yeah it is like you know
anything obviously that we didn't make
him do a whole hour on his head but
having a little cruel but he but he did
say during that classic post-mortem he's
going to talk about he's going to talk a
little bit about the experience of
making making Ichi and all those
available on the GDC for can anyone
access yes so we don't quite do it in
real time because because we're
recording so many talks at the same time
but i would say like maybe once two
weeks after the show you'll be
see all of the classic post-mortems and
we also have the Atari 2600 game
adventure which was the first famously
the first game every time an easter egg
in it and and so I'm excited about that
just because you know honestly some of
these some of these guys are getting a
little bit older is important that they
talk about the games because at some
point they aren't going to be around and
there's going to be a bunch of questions
that we we wish that we wish would have
asked them about how they made the game
so I think doing doing good stuff
forgetting history is good i'm also
quite involved in the indie game summit
and we've managed to pull in some real
interesting talks i'm a big fan of 80
days the iphone game and is actually
yeah should start playing that last week
yes it's an awesome game and actually
there's a there's a couple of talks of
the show and there's one by the writer
make giant who's going to be talking
about you know that the writing for that
game which i think is really interesting
you know there's kind of you know the
steampunk elements to it but there's a
little bit of kind of like romance in
here and all kinds of kind of
interesting things i think you know i
think i think games like that a really
cool and i'm pleased i think especially
with my gaming taste nowadays i like
playing kind of you know fairly fairly
swift fairly swift repeat kind of games
so although some of that is twitch like
stuff like geometry wars i'm only like
playing 80 days because you can get
through it you know decent amount of
time you can replay it there's a lot of
replayability so you know i was going to
i think there was a fear a few years
back that like mobile gaming was just
kind of take over everything in that
hasn't been the case at all yeah and
it's actually and the good thing about
where mobile has gone at this point is
there's a bunch of really interesting
games in around kind of the five Philip
price point I think anyone who's played
games for a long time can still get very
excited about it's just a question
sometimes of finding those games which
yeah i think it's difficult we're
hopefully folks like I thought you could
help out with that well I thought last
year was a great example of a some
fantastic games sort of popping up where
I feel like in previous years perhaps it
was it was more difficult to find real
quality games like between God if it's
so much desert golf of a glass couple of
s you know like and the 80 days as well
of course monument valley as well
another fantastic game which which has
just been so popular between such a
bunch of different ages as well
revisiting old fort like keeping that
that endless runner
keeping it new and fresh it is is
something I'm surprised that people keep
doing of Alto a game I recently started
playing Crossy Road we have such simple
ideas Dahmer show Mike Ross drove for
like two weeks and then I ended up
getting in a taxi yeah just tap top top
top top and asked me for a dollar every
two minutes though which is something i
could do not want to have that anymore
in games yes whatever that's the best
advice I think the good side is you know
you're starting to see and starts the
Apple getting behind some of this you
know recently they famously put up on
their fan page you know that here's some
games you play once yeah and you
actually might be excited to keep
playing it's probably a to play you
might a brand-new concept but yeah but I
mean I think I think that's ultimately
good because you know we you know we
definitely cover we've actually it's
interesting sometimes in the past we've
had people complain because we famously
the hostage ahead a sponsor talk called
Earth safely monetizing teams oh wow wow
there's a title and and it was and what
actually taught us is that we should
screen the talk between the titles of it
yeah sponsor talks because ultimately
that was something that someone actually
you know really clearly what marketers
the sponsor page have yeah but it still
reflect and shitty see that we allowed
it to it so it's still a learning
process exactly so so it so we learned
about that even even even this year you
know there are talks talking about you
know the big spenders the whales in in
in in in free to play and and that's one
that's one whole area but on the other
end we have a bunch of stuff about in DD
sports & v are so so we have them we
have stuff stuff for everyone to get
excited about we will stuff stuff
everyone to get angry about was there
any headline that you got that you
remember you were like oh no no we can't
do that well what was like one
particular talk title well well there
was that one from last year after
service or anything very like old we
since we're vetoing this year did
anything come up in your like no
actually and the first thing about that
was that there were a couple of things
about that talk firstly some p some
people went to went to check it out and
they found it was actually a very
sensible anodyne practical talk yes just
you know they because the concept to
internet outrage you know you can get
quite excited about it but it was
actually a pretty pretty sad to talk
about you know there's all kinds of laws
about that it turns out there's copper
laws about what your men to all right
yeah yeah so these laws on us called CIP
PA
which are about how you how you meant to
target people are under 14 so it was it
was about that but of course I fine TV
season would to be like if there was
ever a conference like I remember always
wanted to go to e3 for years and years
and years being in Ireland and then like
GDC always seemed like an interesting
thing as well but for all the comps I've
ever been to GDC is the one that I come
away with with just feeling like so
humbled about how funny little I know
about games development I remember
watching this talk last year from the
guy from twin beard you made frog
fractions yeah it was basically did an
entire talk about how to like obfuscates
your game to the pot like how to hide
your game from the public and have frog
fractions to it's been Kickstarter it's
probably the best Kickstarter video I've
ever seen and still nobody knows if it's
out yes if it is like has he hidden it
in something and it was an entire talk
about how to hide your game and it's
such a such a crazy concept you never
think of it wouldn't grab a headline on
gamespot or another game site but it was
just such a like interesting insight
into the brain of creators yeah there's
a really easy to Terok start of the show
you know we we actually have a talk this
year in the main conference in design
about how 19th century board games can
can influence today's video game
designer why not like yeah and you know
and i will say you know we try and go
the majority of our talks are quite
practical we have a lot you know as your
viewers my own know we have a lot of
very practical talks about you know
engines and like as you my favorite
practical talk from the issue is with a
talk about how they kept the wildlife
stuck to the ground in FarCry 4 because
it turns out there's actually a really
difficult technical for all right
because all these mountain lions clearly
can't be floating like 10 foot on the
ground and so there's an entire talk 60
minutes on how they kept the wild grapes
to the ground and if you're making a
game with ton of characters and a ton of
mountains that's absolutely a difficult
thing but that's the kind of thing the
average person would just not not think
of it wow that's a bog I would have
liked you've seen in a second Simon
thank you so much for coming in and
talking to us at best of luck next week
and of course a bunch of news from GDC
and also a bunch of talks and of course
the live stream of the GDC choice awards
and the IGF awards will be on gamespot
com next week thank you so much for
watching this week's episode the lobby
please let us know what you think
the comments below will be back next
week of course this GDC it's just down
the road so gonna have a bunch of
developers on the couch showing off
their wares and telling us everything
that's going on down at the conference
for those you who can't make it into
town so we'll see you then enjoy vici
gaming i will see you on the other side